citizens of the reject Nation we are
going to watch the official trailer or
trailer dose for black panther wakanda
forever John good morning 6 a.m how are
you I am wide awake and ready to go how
are you I'm ready to go too got tickets
leave a like leave a like and let's see
what's going on in this trailer
[Music]
[Music]
only the most broken people
[Music]
can't be great leaders
wow guys
the feather serpent God
oh [ __ ] wow
Eternal War
he's coming
in the surface world
coming to the surface World
know what you whisper whoa
stand
oh is that I hurt
laughs
oh my God yes
oh [ __ ]
whoa
I didn't think we had jealous yeah damn
this looks great
oh
[Laughter]
wow wow that was pulse pounding exciting
it was beautiful I feel like both these
trailers have been some of Marvel's best
trailers they've ever done like the
first one was like they're both
emotional in their own ways I mean the
first one you know obviously broke me
but uh this one was very uh just
sweeping and pulse pounding and felt
like inspiring it felt that like
motivation in there to fight for
something you know and I I mean okay we
gotta talk about the suit It's gotta be
sure and that [ __ ] almost like a shirt
that's in Baku definitely a box
yeah uh yeah definitely it looks like
it's a shuri outfit in the way they just
composed the trailer which uh I'm I'm
excited for to see I wonder if they're
gonna do a situation where it would be
Sherry being black panther but would she
also be the leader you know and I'm
curious to see if if it is sure it looks
like it is sure I'm gonna leave with the
idea that it sure yeah you would have to
see her really grow quite a bit into to
being like the Ultimate Warrior though
because you know we didn't really see
much of her train to be like she can
fight but to be the Black Panther as a
whole other skill set level you got to
sort of be at in which he be the the
leader of wakanda after that you know
that's something to unpack but in terms
of what we're immediately getting yeah
it looks like we're dealing with post
the loss of t'challa like the the way
the funeral is being captured looks
obviously very mournful and sorrowful at
the same time it looks like with the way
the least is being represented
culturally at the beginning of this
trailer that it would also be a
celebration as well of the legacy of
t'challa simultaneously you know working
on the celebration of Chadwick Boseman
as well so yeah and then you got anymore
flying around with his little little
wings Little Wings on his ankles yeah
man and I loved what they made of that
because the first trailer has so much
mystery about Neymar and about Atlantis
in general and here you see I feel like
from both perspectives It's like because
we know wakanda much better you know we
feel like that so what our comfort zone
is but yeah you know most of the world
has only just learned about this and I
feel like now they've kind of created a
similar feeling with Atlantis where it's
like now we get to see kind of from the
wakandan's perspective of you know okay
we've got this sort of mystical leader
and his you know people who are now
coming for us and I love to the way like
the Espionage Espionage flavors kind of
compliment that because you know you're
bringing those out of the original black
panther but it also seems like that
element of the story is probably going
to lead directly into the looming
conflict between the wakandans and the
atlanteans and then whatever you know
eventual Alliance comes of that you know
I think will be hard one but yeah like
there's so much in purpose and in you
know this conflict and you can feel that
rousing quality I don't know yeah it's
like there's a rousing sort of
aspirational there's a very sort of like
heart heavy life quality about what the
wakanans are obviously going through and
I feel like that underpinning will make
for like a really interesting
ideological debate too once they act
actually finally get to like peeling
back each other's motivations and
realizing that they probably have a
common enemy or something like that well
in grief oftentimes family has to come
together during that point so I think
that's what this trailer really seemed
to hone in on for for me personally was
the the sense of loss and that's where
the the motivational part comes from is
of fighting together is that now I mean
part of wakanda is that they've always
been together but now more than ever
would that pain imbued into everyone's
performances and their motivation and
what they have to fight for you know
like losing t'challa they're probably
viewed as being a little bit weaker now
and now they have to really prove their
strength I really feel like uh I forget
her name didn't I had to pronounce her
name deny Guerrera Guerra Guerrero
Guerrera her performance in the in this
Trail like just looks so powerful and
looks like she's gonna get a really
badass fight scene too absolutely uh
when in that car or whatever the hell is
going on there and then you see
ironheart flying around a lot more we
still don't exactly know what it is I
mean you could kind of like pull from
Comics it may be some other ideas from
like the previous trailer of why Namor
is fighting specifically but from what
the actor has talked about recently is
that this character is definitely going
to be more portrayed more so as an
anti-hero more so than a direct villain
I'm excited for that to get like a Latin
character in here and then to see the
cultures being represented like that
just expanding upon that even more so I
think it's going to be exciting and
great and the representation I think
would be very powerful and his
performance does look intimidating I'm
glad that they still have kept him a
mystery for the most part because it
there's a lot a lot of things that have
to shine in this movie and then you have
to introduce all these other aspects as
well while dealing with a real the
passing of t'challa Slash Chadwick
Boseman there's so much that this film
has to do in one the run time is two
hours and 41 minutes when I bought the
tickets this morning I was like okay
this really is two hours 41 minutes
which I think is a great run time
especially with all those qualities you
have to jam packed into one film yeah I
mean we got Iron Art here Namor coming
to the surface and uh does feel
threatening and Angela Bassett looks
great as well and Baku looks awesome
like every uh it this this feels
um like a Monumental point for the
Marvel films and I I it doesn't look
funny
it looks cultural and purposeful and
heavy and like there will be some kind
of if it is shuri I bet there's a really
really vital coming of age in a rough
you know situation story that that you
can ring out I think the fact that they
showed it is the thing that like
surprised me the most that's like
because it could be Okoye it could be
and that's what gets me wondering if
yeah if they're misleading us or if
they're I don't know you know if there
might be if she might Don the Black
Panther suit but maybe there will be
somebody else who works alongside her in
a capacity like it it feels like there's
a definitive aspect but it's not the
whole picture you know yeah all right
guys well that's the Black Panther
wakanda forever official trailer what
did you all think leave your thoughts
down below and be sure to subscribe
click that Bell leave a like we'll catch
you all soon
[Music]